pft on yahoo sports peter king and mike
florio talking about some of the biggest
stories in the national football league
and in the aftermath
of the week three monday night game
between the chiefs and the ravens a
34-20 victory by kansas city
snapping a 14-game regular season
winning streak by baltimore
does the performance peter king of
quarterback lamar jackson the defending
mvp raise any red flags for you
oh definitely and mike first of all this
is not a big
game thing okay lamar jackson last year
won plenty of big games uh and you can't
tell me that playing the eight no
patriots
uh in prime time at home and killing
them
uh is not a big game that's a big game
you can't tell me
beating the 49ers in a huge game when
they're whatever they are ten and one or
ten and two
that's not a big game that's a big game
you can't tell me going to seattle
last year and beating the seahawks is
not a big those are big games they're
big wins
here's what bothers me about lamar
jackson
tell me how he plays when he gets
slugged in the jaw
in the first half tell me how he plays
having to come from behind and
uh and and look it's it's it's bad
and i agree i heard everybody talking
last night well
you know his teammates are not helping
him you know the offensive line was
terrible he had five drops by his
receivers i get that
but come on you watch the game he played
poorly and that's putting it nicely uh
he was not he did not throw an accurate
ball
i think my overriding concern mike
about jackson is that you're not going
to get up by 10
in the first 15 minutes of every game
you play when you can just start
running and rolling downhill on people
okay
football is not like that and the ravens
are finding that out
when they get behind a really good team
they really have trouble coming back
and playing their game and to me a good
deal of it comes down to the
accuracy of lamar jackson in those games
yeah and 10 when trailing at halftime
with lamar jackson as the starter and we
saw it last night
when the ravens were down 14 points
and they were trying to cut it from 34
20 to 34 27. you could see the demeanor
the frustration
you know with the chiefs it's all so
easy and loose and they know they're
always gonna find a way out of the maze
no matter how lost they may feel
and i feel like when the ravens are
behind in the fourth quarter and you're
right the downhill running isn't working
you have to pass to try to get back in
the game
they just haven't gotten the offense to
evolve to the point where they can score
those points when they need those points
in order to erase a deficit late in the
game
yeah and you don't see what you see with
mahomes which is
under pressure i mean and who does this
mahomes and russell wilson
that's about it you know who hits a
pass that goes 58 yards in the air right
into the hands of machole hardman
uh you know where it looks like
you know it looks like it looks like
patrick mahomes is
deep at the center field fence and just
unleashes a ball
unleashes a ball and throws it to home
plate as far as
as hard as he can and that's what he did
in this game
but mike coming back to lamar jackson
he has to get in the huddle and say
we're stopping the bleeding right now
we are doing this right now and i have
no idea what he says his teammates
love him capital l love him i've seen it
i've been at training camp i've been in
their locker room you can see it
they trust him the trust has not gone
away however
he has got to prove that he can play
better when he's down to a good team
period that's all there is to it
remember that moment last year against
seattle when he went to the sideline and
he basically said to john harbaugh we're
going for it on fourth down
that's what he should have done last
night on that first drive you don't take
field goals when you can get touchdowns
against the kansas city chiefs or you're
not going to win peter
yeah i would agree and the one other
quick thing
show some confidence instead of a little
bit of that hang dog
look which you saw last night with him
all right check us out all season long
for pft on yahoo videos he's peter king
i'm mike floria we'll see you next time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports